so we start at the first rank three one
is smaller than three so gets a minus
four is greater so gets a plus two is
smaller so it gets a minus six is
greater so gets a plus and five is also
greater so it also gets a plus now we do
the same for one here of course each
subsequent rank is greater than one so
we have a plus everywhere at rank four
two is smaller and six and five are
greater now we do this for rank two and
rank six then we can easily calculate
the number of concordant and discordant
pairs we get the number of concordant
pairs by counting all the Plus in our
example we have 11 plus in total we get
the number of these coordin pairs by
counting all the minus in our example we
have a total of four minus C is thus
eleven and D is four candles Tau now is
eleven minus four divided by eleven plus
four